[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec à cynthia
fleury professeur titulaire de la chaire
l'humanité et santé au conservatoire
national des arts et métiers
bonjour cynthia fleury merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france vous tenait un
journal de confiner au jour le jour
depuis le début de cette mesure
nationale confinement inédit certaines
études montrent que cela a et aura des
conséquences négatives sur la population
est lesquelles selon vous vous avez une
revue important qui s'appelle de landes
7 et qui a fait une synthèse à partir de
24 études et donc que là c'est vrai que
derrière la question du confinement il
ya une pluralité des confinement et ça
c'est très important pour évaluer la
question du stress parce que selon que
vous ayez des maladies chroniques selon
que vous soyez immunodéficients ou pas
que vous soyez a dit que vous soyez
âgées dépendants que vous soyez bien
évidemment dans une vulnérabilité socio
économique forte
bien évidemment les stress face à
l'infection à la peur de l'infection ou
ce qu'on appelle encore la détresse
socio-économique tout ça va être très
très très variable et donc les études
elle montre que oui pour 30 à 40 %
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs pourquoi bas sans doute parce
qu'il ya des alternatives ya du
télétravail
il ya un sentiment d'être actif d'être
aussi plus résistants face à la maladie
donc voilà il ya énormément de il ya une
granularité si vous voulez face à la
vérité du confinement c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites le sentiment d'être
utile est ce que ça joue aussi dans ce
confinement
c'est essentiel c'est d'abord ce que
nous disent aussi les soignants parce
que dans il ya les déconfit nez si j'ose
dire qu' aussi ont un stress très
important et un épuisement professionnel
très fort qu'on connaissait avant la
crise du coc vie d'un donc ce n'est pas
spécifique à la crise ducobu enfin il ya
un réel de
la mort qui est beaucoup plus fort avec
la crise du coc vide et ils le disent
ils leur disent ils se sentent utiles et
c'est à la fois éprouvant mais ça les
recharges et ça leur donne de la force
et c'est pour ça que à 20h les uns et
les autres
quand on vient leur témoigner entre
guillemets de notre ferveur ils sont
extrêmement voilà c'est la même chose
aussi pour le livreur pour les postiers
pour les caissiers c'est à dire que vous
avez un sentiment d'être aussi au front
et mettre en danger donc un stress plus
fort mais vous avez aussi en contrebas
lancement un sentiment d'être utile donc
voilà il ya de la résilience qui se
situe aussi au coeur de l'épreuve depuis
le début de cette crise des français
sont sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement
là aussi ça a été bien documenté
notamment dans la revue du land 7 qui
explique ba oui ça crée de la confusion
donc ça crée aussi un stress alors c'est
très compliqué pourquoi parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'information il ya un stress
et on considère qu' on n'est pas informé
mal informés d informer ce sont les
théories complotistes qui monte
et puis si on est trop informés c'est de
nouveau un stress parce que c'est
mortifère parce que c'est un décompte
qui tout d'un coup vous donne un
sentiment là aussi de menaces face à la
mort donc ce juste milieu de l'as de la
limitation intelligente face aux écrans
face à l'information il faut la trouver
et elle varie en plus selon les âges
reste un confinement effectivement
doublé d'une angoisse très forte liée au
risque de mortalité est ce que c'est le
confinement qui pèse vous est ce que
c'est la peur de mourir
non c'est pas tellement on va pas
seulement alors là aussi ça dépend les
catégories mais en grande majorité ce
n'est pas la peur de l'infection ou de
là haut ou de la contamination c'est la
peur quand même socio économique c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même une détresse
socio économique très très fortes
notamment pour pour les actifs bien
évidemment plus vous êtes âgé plus vous
avez peur du réel de la mort c'est
évident mais en revanche vous avez
quelque chose d'une angoisse très très
forte sur la récession du pouvoir
d'achat
ah le fait que les conséquences en fait
du confinement et le poste confinement
et comment on va sortir l'atteindra tj
la stratégie de sortie et très peu
lisible
elle crée donc là aussi un sentiment de
de résilience compliqué parce qu'on se
dit mon dieu ça va durer des mois
cette histoire non pas le confinement
lui-même mais les conséquences du
confinement est donc oui c'est c'est
quelque chose là aussi qu'il varie selon
les âges et l'affect tranquille le
dessus sur la raison et dans quelle
proportion sulu pareil la russie c'est
très très variables tout dépend les
ressources que l'on a il est évident que
tous ceux qui sont des hyper active des
anxieux des dépressifs des addicts etc
ont une tendance à tout simplement à
moins d'y gérer ce phénomène là et puis
vous avez aussi il faut pas que être
négative dans cette histoire là ce sont
des épreuves des épreuves c'est de ce
sont des inédits et donc qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui se saisissent de
ce moment pour dire mon dieu il faut en
faire nécessairement quelque chose comme
une approche très vite à liszt et donc
il ya pas mal de résolution
ce qui est aussi de l'émotion si vous
voulez mais de l'émotion de rescousse si
j'ose dire c'est à dire qu'on se dit mon
dieu il faut absolument faire quelque
chose et est donc c'est aussi
intéressant de voir cela c'est pas
forcément la chose la plus simple
je pense notamment à toute une série
d'un groupe d'addicts que je suis de
poly addict que je suis et arrêter la
diction dans le confinement ça
paraîtrait logique mais c'est plus
compliqué que ça est-ce que ça on
voulait l'être humain peut gérer une
proximité quotidienne avec sa famille
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça resserre les liens ou au
contraire est-ce que ça les haltères là
aussi si vous voulez il faut pas faut
pas demander au confinement ce qui ne
peut pas faire je veux dire par là que
si vous ne vous entendiez pas avec votre
famille avant le confinement il ya peu
de chance tout de même que le
confinement face variés cela c'est
pareil pour les couples les crises
conjugales tout ça hélas
voilà seule la vérité d'une crise elle
dit souvent landau gènes d'une d'une
relation ce qu'on peut voir tout de même
c'est que chez les plus jeunes les
enfants qui ont pas les plus petits
parce que les plus petits s'en rendent
pas nécessairement compte mais ceux qui
ont entre sept et 12 ans vu qu'il ya
tout de même une crise de la parentalité
que les parents sont souvent pas là que
le monde d'aujourd'hui dessert les liens
entre les parents et les enfants
il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui sont assez
heureux de pouvoir vivre ce moment c'est
je ne dis pas que c'est la même chose du
côté des parents les parents c'est la
même chose mais c'est plus difficile
pour eux parce qu'ils doivent concilier
télétravail et les enfants et
l'accompagnement du téléenseignement et
c'est pas si simple
mais du côté des enfants c'est plutôt
ressenti comme un moment très fort avec
les parents l'allemagne elle n'a pas
opté 1 pour le confinement par crainte
des risques d'augmentation des suicides
surtout c'est chez les personnes vivant
seules c'est ce qu'a dit le gouvernement
allemand est ce que c'est le casse où
l'on vous a écouté je pense que oui je
pense qu'il faudra faire un grand retour
d'expérience dans quelques mois pour
vérifier quelles sont les stratégies les
plus probantes pour protéger la vie
parce qu'on voit très bien l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est de protéger la vie la
question c'est de savoir si protéger là
on protège mieux la vie en mettant comme
seul et unique critère la vie ou si
est-ce qu'on protège mieux la vie ici et
maintenant et demain en articulant des
critères et en produisant déconfinement
éventuellement à géométrie variable
et ça c'est sans doute le cas parce
qu'on voit bien qu'on n'est pas tous les
mêmes on n'est pas tous égaux dans notre
capacité de subir le confinement et les
effets délétères ne seront pas les mêmes
autre personne très seules les personnes
âgées bien évidemment qui sont en
confinement individuel en maison de
retraite ou chez elle comment les aider
à traverser cette crise oui parce que le
voyez là c'est l'exemple typique des
effets délétères du confinement
pourquoi parce que si vous voulez ce qui
se joue à 90 ans 91 ans et cetera c'est
un irréversible un ya passé par
rattrapable si vous laissez pas une
parenthèse et donc tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui traverse ce moment ils
savent que c'est du temps qui ne
rattraperont
donc ça les angoisses davantage et puis
par ailleurs ils ont besoin terriblement
besoin des liens sociaux pour se sentir
tout simplement vivant et donc là il est
clair qu'on a manqué de discernement
alors que ça y est on commence un ca y
est les ehpad se sont unis de tablettes
de tous qu'elle de voilà pourquoi parce
que c'est ça l'enjeu éthique l'enjeu
éthique c'est de produire des
alternatives et pas simplement de
produire de la règle il faut vivre il
faut bien sûr produire des règles
produire du consentement à cette règle
mais produire aussi de la non
discrimination par rapport à cette règle
et donc des ajustements et donc dans les
ehpad par exemple c'est nécessaire c'est
vrai de repenser comment on va permettre
restaurer ce lien essentiel pour la
santé des résidents
on le voit il ya l'urgence des malades à
traiter mais est ce qu'il existe des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
pour gérer cette détresse psychologique
actuel
quelle sera l'ampleur des problèmes
psychologiques a à gérer selon vous à la
sortie du confinement
alors les problèmes y sont déjà là donc
ils seront là ils sont ici et maintenant
vous avez toute la question bien
évidemment du deuil
on le sait c'est très problématique donc
tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu faire mais
crée le rituel autour de la mort de ceux
qui sont partis donc ça c'est un point
important il ya toute la détresse socio
économique qui va se maintenir puisque
la situation derrière
bien sûr il ya des plans massifs
d'investissements qui sont annoncés mais
on sait que ça ne va pas être aussi
simple que ça alors les dispositifs de
soutien ils sont très nombreux et ils
sont c'est ce qui est aussi une demande
de l'om s ils sont ciblés
c'est à dire que vous avez toute une
liste maintenant des soutiens que ce
soit pour les soignants pour les malades
chroniques
pour ceux qui ont le cancer pour les
enfants pour les aînés etc
c'est à dire qu'on est en train
véritablement de de perfectionner ce
soutien parce qu'on sait à quel point
c'est là c'est la singularité des êtres
si vous voulez qu'il va falloir
accompagner dans ce moment de
rétablissement par le biais de deux
numéros de téléphone à disposition
j'imagine tout à fait d'aider des
numéros verts les sites bien évidemment
internet il ya beaucoup de groupes au
psy whatsapp qui se sont mis en place
dès sur les réseaux sociaux dont si vous
voulez il ya même des tchats communs qui
existent vous pouvez vous là aussi
grimper sur le live
donc c'est toutes ces solutions elles
sont oui oui elles sont répertoriées
aujourd'hui on a accès à tout cela assez
facilement et on voit des comportements
qui ont été dénoncées vous en parler ou
également cynthia fleury ce sont ces
personnes qui dénoncent des voisins qui
sortirait de leur domicile ou même des
soignantes qui ont été priés de
déménager comment est-ce que vous
expliquer qu'on en arrive à de tels
comportements
c'était là c'est une vérité très
archaïque du genre humain on voit dans
des moments comme ça inédit même hors
moments inédits on voit toujours là pour
la polarité du genre humain le pire et
le meilleur
et c'est vrai que oui on a eu un retour
assez fort une recrudescence qui est pas
spécifiquement française vous avez vu un
l'année se croient que c'est en nouvelle
zélande où il ya eu un site qui s'est
entièrement dédié à la délation pseudo
citoyenne
l'histoire nous a montré qu'il ya eu des
grands moments comme ça où on demandait
aux citoyens de faire ce travail de
surveillance amer il faut absolument
résister à cela il faut le condamner
la police française là à les condamner
un peu légèrement enfin en disant
écoutez non on va essayer simplement de
faire de la verbalisation sur le terrain
public
et puis tout quand même en allant faire
un tour à chaque fois qu'on lui faisait
un signalement sur tel ou tel barque
était ouvert on va parler du rythme un à
la maison en ce moment qui est
complètement modifié pour les enfants
ils doivent suivre des cours sur les
ordinateurs
le confinement est il plus difficile
pour les ados les
donc qui on le sait ont besoin d'être
loin de leurs parents oui il est
forcément plus difficile alors il il est
plus difficile parce que en plus il ya
une chose un peu un peu étonnante
m'enfin pas étonnante une choses
basiques de l'adolescence c'est que
c'est un moment de transgression c'est
un moment où on s'émancipe c'était un
moment où on se tient à distance des
règles et là de fait d'être
particulièrement contraindre n'est pas
nécessairement plus plus simple et puis
par ailleurs les vêtements sur les toute
la question de l'enseignement du
téléenseignement il est de moins bonne
qualité que l'enseignement supérieur
donc on voit que quand on est au niveau
supérieur
l'outil est assez robuste et plus on
descend et plus l'outil est défaillant
et donc plus les pales les parents sont
sur ce lit cité alors même que en tout
cas pour l'adolescence et pas
nécessairement le moment où on a envie
d'être confronté aux parents alors pour
les parents j'imagine que c'est un point
positif de pouvoir avoir leur adolescent
avec eux comment peut-il gérer cette
distanciation normale en tout cas entre
adolescents et adultes est ce que les
adultes doivent leur laisser aussi un
peu de un peu de distance un peu de un
peu d'air si vous voulez dans ces
moments où on est tous ensemble et
contraint oui on réinvente les modalités
de d'accaparement de l'espace après là
aussi tout dépend de l'endroit où ils
vivent et comment vous vivez et cetera
mais est évident que chaque famille
réinvente son quotidien
essaye à la fois de préserver des
rituels ensemble et en même temps de
laisser c'est vrai les uns et les autres
dans leur propre vie alors il ya les
outils là aussi sociaux permettent de
faire ça il ya quantité d'adolescents
qui se donnent rendez vous à telle heure
parce qu'il ya toute la question aussi
de la découverte amoureuse la la
découverte amoureuse avec digital
essentiellement mais les écrans aussi on
va en parler c'est un problème récurrent
temps normal les adolescents et les
enfants sont beaucoup sur les écrans en
ce moment mais c'est aussi un moyen de
rester en contact alors comment faire la
part des choses
c'est très compliqué là aussi j'ai pas
mal de deux parents patients qui
ben voilà qui savent plus faire
puisqu'en gros l'ordinateur est ouvert
toute la journée donc entre les cours
les moments où on fait du lien social
par l'ordinateur et les moments où on
surf et où on fait du loisir c'est assez
compliqué donc il ya une saturation des
écrans d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
migraine ya beaucoup de les yeux piquent
les oreilles etc
on est en train de découvrir aussi si
vous voulez que tout ce qui concerne la
perception de la téléprésence n'est pas
si simple
c'est quelque chose de lourd c'est
quelque chose d'épuisants donc il ya
beaucoup d'adolescents qui se disent
fatigués pourquoi parce que c'est la
vérité
décor un les corps pour se régénérer ils
doivent sortir ils doivent bouger ils
doivent aller respirer et donc on fait
les preuves aussi là en ce moment de 2,7
de 700 utilité mise à mal est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir ce sentiment de suspicion
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent également qu'ils rentrent
chez eux
comment gérer cette suspicion de la
contamination au sein même du lieu de
confinement pas toujours en respectant
les les gestes barrières et c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué c'est
particulièrement compliquée avec les
enfants parce que plus ils sont petits
plus pas moins ils sont aptes à
respecter les gestes barrières sans
parler bien évidemment des bd ou si vous
faites des gestes barrières avec des
bébés bien vous les mettez en danger
donc résultat vous êtes dans cette voie
là aussi ce sont des agencements il faut
faire attention on sait tout de même que
les formes sévères chez nos aînés bah
c'est extraordinairement dangereux donc
s'il ya plusieurs générations dans une
dans une famille on essaye de prioriser
de faire en sorte que les les plus les
plus âgés soient les moins en contact
avec les autres bien évidemment en
respectant les deux mètres où les 1
mètre 50 en août ont aussi certaines
personnes dire je suis en prison à cause
du confinement assez exagéré selon alors
c'est exagéré oui et non tout dépend
encore une fois du lieu
tout dépend de l'endroit où vous vivez
si vous voulez c'est une
le confinement fait éclater ce qu'on
connaît depuis toujours à savoir la
vérité des fractures sociales donc oui
c'est évident que certains sont en
prison parce qu'il vit dans des petites
chambres qui n'ont absolument aucun
soleil dans des endroits je ne sais où
et cetera donc bien évidemment mais
sinon bah sinon de toute façon vu que
c'est une obligation il faut essayer de
renverser comme toujours la propriété la
proposition est donc essayer encore une
fois d'en faire quelque chose et c'est
pour ça que c'est assez intéressant de
voir que toutes les ressources
culturelles
on a pu s'en moque et au début trouvé
que c'était superfétatoire en fait non
c'est pas superfétatoire
c'est très important que le monde de la
culture se mobilisent comme aujourd'hui
je pense aux séances d'opéra qui tout
d'un coup voilà alors bien évidemment
avec encore une fois cette réalité de la
fracture numérique qui est que si vous
n'avez pas un ordinateur si vous n'avez
pas un téléphone 4g etc vous avez moins
encore une fois accès à cela donc
résultat des livres des livres pour ceux
qui peuvent retourner vers cette vérité
première du ressourcement littéraire
comment est ce que on va pouvoir gérer
psychologiquement la sortie le risque
sera toujours présent on le voit bien
avec l'exemple chinois
il faut donner une perspective néanmoins
à la population comment faire il va
falloir donner effectivement une
perspective et va falloir aussi sans
doute à voir dans le scope la dent dans
la vision que nous devons réapprendre le
goût je dirais pour que ça soit pas
ressenti comme une contrainte est comme
une entrave le goût du comportement
collectif voilà le goût un peu d' une
autodiscipline le goût du civisme parce
que si nous vivons ça simplement comme
une manière de une restriction de nos
libertés individuelles comme si nous ne
vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire des
uns et des autres
ça va être la extraordinairement durs en
revanche si nous considérons que nous ne
perdons pas dans cette histoire parce
que nos libertés sont pendant un certain
temps
articulé on va dire plus articulés les
unes entre elles
là en revanche on peut au contraire
avoir à les ddd réflexion nouvelle sur
la manière dont nous envisageons nos
relations les uns avec les autres
c'est vraiment une une ridicule exemple
de tout le monde l'a fait ces derniers
temps s'il voulait avec le fameux les à
20h les applaudissements au début on
applaudit en l'air et puis au bout de
deux trois quatre cinq fois on discute
avec tous les voisins on se salue on
fait connaissance etc
donc si vous les voilà cet armement
donné il faut attraper l'inédit d'une
crise pour vivre de façon le plus
positive et surtout pour apprendre pour
tirer des leçons et pas nous y sente
pour aller le maximum d'entre nous une
dernière question cynthia fleury est ce
que cette crise va changer durablement
nos comportements est-ce que cela va
accentuer les individualismes le repli
sur soi ou bien au contraire approchés
les personnes alors si vous voulez sur
les questions d'application je dirais
très direct il est clair que ça va avoir
quand même une grande importance au
niveau des usages sévit dans tout ce qui
concerne la téléprésence le
télé-enseignement les téléconsultations
le comment dire enfin bref tout ce qui
est tous est le télétravail bien
évidemment il est évident que cela on va
avoir une grande modification de notre
de notre manière de vivre sur le côté
mais t'as plus plus philosophique plus
idéologique
bah c'est tout l'enjeu c'est tout
l'enjeu parce qu'effectivement si après
la crise du covin nous allons vers plus
de néolibéralisme et d'austérité nous
iront nécessairement vers du repli vers
de la culture de la violence de la
survie vers du ressentiment croissant si
au contraire nous enclenchons un
tournant social démocrate
l'histoire n'est pas à ce moment-là
écrite de façon aussi fatale si j'ose
dire merci beaucoup cynthia fleury pour
vos conseils et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france merci à vous
pour votre fidélité
restez chez vous et avec nous
[Musique]